[Music]
[Applause]
back by popular demand Tim Hasselbeck
great appearance last time he was on
former NFL quarterback and works for the
mothership although also the ACC Network
he will be uh in Chapel Hill it's Duke
in North Carolina coming up this
Saturday on the ACCC Network let me
start with last night here let's start
with the Jets can you pinpoint one major
problem with this team like what's the
one that stands out
H um listen I not to be crazy obvious
look I think the I mean the quarterback
is Big major issue I it's just
surprising to me I think I I see guys
play sometimes Dan and it's like they're
unlocked they're free they're you know
they're not worried about making
mistakes and I just feel
like there's an element sometimes when
you watch other guys that they're just
paralyzed like I know they're better
players than what we see I know they're
better athletes than what we see but
there's just something whether like the
building or the game plan or whatever it
is has just made them feel like all
right they just want me to not screw up
like that's what they want me to not do
and I think when you do that just not as
good like just there's an element of
being you know relaxed and confident
that I think you know there's a Carefree
to be able to play the position
sometimes that I think is important but
when you go to the line of scrimmage and
you're thinking about blocking
assignments you're thinking about the
pass rush I mean he's forced to think
about other things I don't know if he
can have tunnel vision when he goes up
there and goes hey it's just like when I
was at BYU I don't have to worry about
anything I can freelance he doesn't have
that opportunity with as bad as that
offensive line is yeah no that I mean
listen that's fair pass protection me
just look around the league guys that
play well often times it's because that
week like they've got a clean pocket I
mean there's just about everybody that's
playing in the league is going to do
better in that environment I think what
I'm more referring to is like um look
you look at some of these quarterbacks
that go out there I'll give you like um
the kid in Chicago beiget this week I
thought there was a carefreeness to how
he played like which surprised me a
little bit based on how he struggled the
week before I think you look at Josh dos
and like you come into that environment
it's like listen man like I'm not going
to bog myself down and slow myself down
by thinking about all the bad things
that might happen like I I there's an
element of cutting it loose and I'm not
saying be Reckless but I think there's
an element of guys just looking hesitant
at times I just I feel like you see that
a little bit with Zach and I think
because of the o line because of just
some of the things they're dealing with
like you need him you need his
athleticism and his ability
to be an asset not something that
doesn't shine through what is the major
motivation for Aaron Rogers to try to
come back this
year um listen I think you just run out
of time age injury like an appreciation
for look how old he is what he's been
through in his career and then you know
look I think everybody that has had
success like he's had or close to it
like there's this chip right that in
compe iess that's different than other
players like there are plenty of people
like look I'm making a lot of money I'm
going to get better I'll see you next
year but I think there's an element of
look I just did something that no one
else has done I think really really
great players are motivated by things
like that so um yeah I think that those
are probably the things that factor into
him the most feels like he wants to
prove something modern medicine wise
like that's really important that's why
he's out there throwing the football he
wants you to see he wants you to
Chronicle this he wants this to go viral
and look you know whatever his
interpretation of modern medicine is and
what he's pushing and what he believes
in good for him because if it works for
him that's all that matters it feels
like that might be at the the front of
this that I want to I want to get back I
don't know if he can play and help them
if he should come back and play but it
feels like there's a couple of
motivations at least you know from the
outside looking in yeah and and listen I
I think you know we're probably both
speculating that that' be the case but
how about this like I don't disagree
with you to think about great players
and that when Adrien Peterson came back
from his ACL injury and it was six
months what do we do look at Adrien
Peterson this guy's not human he's
coming back from that injury after six
months and then next thing you know it's
like Wes Welker does his ACL like oh how
fast is West coming back and now of a
sudden like that's changed the game game
where we go guy to his ACL like so what
man like six months he's going to be
better than he was before and like that
doesn't happen with like the journeyman
player like that's not the but it's the
great player that does it and now of a
sudden he changes everyone's expectation
for it so look I think you're right you
know like only Aaron would really be
able to tell us but like if he changes
the game in terms of teing your Achilles
and how you come back that's a big deal
to someone like him I bet Daniel Jones
tearing his
ACL what do you let me put you in the
front office with the Giants what are
you going to do at the quarterbacking
position yeah look I I think you need to
um look I I don't think they've had
their guy I think the contract this year
like I just haven't felt that way um
look I I think the success last year was
a little bit of Fool's Gold I think
Daniel's tough and competitive and all
that and they have a ton of respect for
a guy that tears his ACL and I think
tries to keep playing not knowing how
badly you hurt himself like everyone's
got to understand like like that's the
type of competitor is that's great but I
know this like you mentioned the game I
have this weekend I know a lot of people
talk about KB Williams Drake May is to
me about as perfect of a prospect that I
have ever seen in 15 years edn like I
like there are good quarterbacks coming
out in this draft you're going to have a
bad team I understand and you know you
you resigned Daniel Jones to a uh you
know a big contract last year and all of
that I think if you're in the market for
one of these guys that I believe is
going to be really really good I think
you got to get involved in that game and
Drake May for me Dan would be at the top
L West Tim Hasselbeck ESPN ACC football
analyst former NFL quarterback let me
stay on that because I think orlovski uh
we've had a couple of analysts who have
been it it felt like it we moved away
from Caleb Williams because we wanted to
bring in other quarterbacks into the
conversation and then I wondered Michael
penck Jr and Caleb uh you know is it one
a 1B one C in your opinion with these
quarterbacks I here's what I think I
think in the evaluation process of these
guys well first off all three of them
ridiculously talented right and I think
a lot of people are gonna say yeah this
guy's good enough productive enough
projects enough to be a first-rounder I
think when people sit down and talk to
Drake
I think that it it's going to look like
there's nothing wrong with them I think
when you talk through I he's going to be
a better Pro than college player uh his
size his athleticism the way he moves
like he to me is already like will be in
a class of just physically talented and
then also like like uh size ability how
he sees things to Herbert and momes and
Josh Allen those guys that are like
every bit of you know 64 to 66 run crazy
see it well you know insanely
competitive like he's gonna be like that
he's checking all of those boxes and
then he's just a young kid still that I
think is GNA get better in the pros when
you can control the game because of how
smart he is so I'm gonna give you the
number one pick Tim Tim you're the
Cardinals you're on the clock yeah I'm
taking them taking Drake me yeah okay
that's a quick answer
I am yeah so you know listen I think
that look I haven't because I do AC
games Dan you know obviously you know I
haven't had a Washington game I haven't
had an sc game but you know I'm watching
this stuff like everybody else I just
know that you know from talking to
people um and like seeing what he's like
in the building and just his competitive
nature combined with his ability like he
does things that other guys just don't
do that I think really translates to the
to the next level let me ask you a
couple of NFL questions um how does
Baltimore physically dominate you know
they dominated the the Lions and they
dominated Seattle those are teams that I
wouldn't think would be physically
dominated what is it that Baltimore is
doing and what makes them a sneaky Super
Bowl pick yeah I mean I think
defensively we all would probably agree
they've got an aggressive Ive physical
front so like look that they're not
going to get bullied by anybody on that
side of the ball and then I think
offensively you know as much as we've
talked about hey this passing game is
going to be different and I think that
there are elements of um you know in the
pocket passing that have definitely
improved because of the nature of what
they can do offensively with their
personnel meaning look the guys up front
they're tight end they're fullback the
backs that they have and then the threat
of what the quarterback can do giving
you a number count advantage in the Run
game like Run game is numbers and angles
you know and so they get extra uh
elements of that because of their
quarterback that helps you be physical
and then they've done a good job with
some of the pass game stuff off of it so
I think that that um is what makes them
special what makes them a team that
could beat Kansas City could beat Miami
could beat any of these other teams in
the AFC on the way to the Super Bowl who
do you have a better sense of who they
are the Dolphins or the
Cowboys um I think I have a better sense
of who the Dolphins are uh than the
Cowboys and I will say this like I
actually came away Sunday night more
impressed with Dallas than less
impressed like I think it was easy to be
like hey I'm gonna focus on this last 70
seconds of the football game and be like
ah Dallas what a disaster but really I
was like I I saw a quarterback play
extremely well I thought Dak did a good
job running when he needed to run he
certainly passed the ball extremely well
I thought that the defense did a good
job of not allowing Philadelphia to run
the football like I I you know there
obviously elements that that game could
have been different so I do think I'm
encouraged by Dallas but what I do know
about like I know there's an identity in
Miami like of what they want to do how
they want to do things and I think that
it takes a lot for them to get away from
that whereas like I feel like with
Dallas you could get a game where you
know Pard has 28 carries and then you
could get a game where six carries like
I I just don't think that you're that
unsure about what you might see uh for
Miami you played under Andy Reid in
Philly you played under Steve Spurrier
in Washington what's the what's the
biggest difference between those
two um well I would say this but the the
one constant before I go there one
constant is like I think both guys
actually did a great job of having you
be like relaxed talking about
quarterbacks getting paralyzed and stuff
like I think coach fer because he played
the position you know he was great at
getting Guys open he wanted you to be
relaxed Andy does the same exact thing
um you know I just would say probably
the biggest thing with Andy is even
though he is relaxed like there's no
stone unturned like the level of detail
for a guy that's very relaxed that keeps
team meetings really short
um I think is remarkable that's a really
hard balance of not being somebody
that's like hey you know don't forget to
do this but don't forget to do that and
oh yeah hey if the safety's High then
remember we're checking this like and
all of a sudden like you can paralyze
somebody like he's details but also
relaxed you know I think that's that's
really cool so hey I I want to do this I
was listening to the show Dan and I
don't I I don't I can't I can't get off
this segment without being like thank
you for your
um your your advice on you know father
of the bride speeches groomsmen speeches
like I I was at you know I've been at so
many weddings I left one uh not that
long ago with my brother and it was like
Hey listen there should be a college
class on on rehearsal dinner speeches or
wedding speeches like we don't near need
to hear about the time that like you
were nearly arrested after the Limp
Biscuit concert like we don't need that
like now's not the time like give the
compliment like it's okay right let's go
have you ever given a speech best man
speech I I've given a best man speech
brother's wedding friends wedding I've H
I have a daughter who's in high school
so I'm not there yet but like I heard
you talking about like where you'll be
one time with that like listen it I'm
showering with praise at that point okay
like that like I'm not I'm not going in
it's not the time to to to to give a
hard time you didn't give me your
favorite Spurrier story you have to have
a few of those I I I have a very good
sper story
um we were we were playing the Giants I
don't know if I told this before we're
playing the Giants and it snowed like
five inches uh in New York the night
before so they plow the the field before
the game but it's freezing cold and uh
and then you know it's the second half
and it's freezing out still and I just
remember I'm I'm sitting on the bench um
you know they got the heaters coming out
of them and I'm right next to lus schs
and Coach spier comes over to us and our
defense is on the field it's like third
down and um and we're freezing and he's
spacing the two of us and he's freezing
and LC looks up at him and he's like hey
coach and he kind of moves over and he's
like you can sit down if you want and
he's like oh LC I wish that I could I
wish that I
could he was different he was different
he didn't care about the defense did he
even know the guy names on the defense
there in Washington uh I'm sure he knew
the names I will say this and I know you
know that time didn't work out but I
feel like you know there's something to
learn from any good coach he obviously
is a really really good coach and um
there are a lot of things I learned from
him and um
listen every every every level is
different every situation is different
but uh at least for me it was a lot of
fun for me to play for safe travels down
there to North Carolina thanks for
joining us again Tim thanks Dan Tim
Hassel back ESPN also working for the
ACC former NFL quarterback uh he's got
Duke in North Carolina Tim's in love
Tim's in love with Drake May